what do you think of open ai as applied
to video games
i don't know like
i'm not really that familiar with
everything openai is doing like i know
you know they've done the gpt models of
you know language processing and then
people have found weird ways of applying
that to all sorts of things that are not
the original application i don't know
what else they're working on
i do think that
like that general kind of deep learning
neural network thing has a lot of
applicability in games
um
places that come to mind right away are
like making animations more believable
that's interesting stuff like that maybe
[Music]
making
voice synthesis finally happen right
because there's this thing where in a
game
you have voi you have voice actors
reading
pre-written stuff and if you're trying
to do a world like fallout or something
where a lot of different things could
happen
you just have to pre-record a bunch of
lines but the actors can't really act
the lines that well because it's this
super non-linear space of like they
don't know what's happening right
also honestly
the
the procedure by which video games
record this kind of acting is not
actually conducive to good acting so
the actors who are good have done a
really good job of like working within
that format to generate good results
right
um
i forgot where i was going to go from
there but uh you were thinking of
applications of open ai to video games
yeah i mean so oh so there's sort of a
trade-off right i think
if you wanted to do a game like that by
actually generating the text
procedurally and then having a character
speak it with like an ai generated voice
i think in the short term
that's not as good of acting
nearly as like if you have an actual
actor do it
but then again there's lots of video
games with bad acting and people think
that's fine
so
maybe you can make a trade-off where the
amount of stuff you could do in the game
is so much higher or the amount of
possibility space is so much bigger that
it's fine that the acting isn't
necessarily that good and you
consciously make that trade off right